considering the huge success of the
first two movies in the Transformers
franchise director Michael Bay didn't
take Megan Fox's firing from
Transformers Dark of the Moon lightly
luckily for BA the main character's love
interest isn't what drives ticket sales
in an action movie about automobile
robots with a simple offscreen breakup
Fox was replaced by a new girlfriend
played by Rosie Huntington whitle why
exactly was Fox cut in a 2009 interview
with Wonderland Fox made some comments
about B's onset Behavior comparing him
to a certain fascist dictator the actor
told the outlet he's like Napoleon and
he wants to create this insane Infamous
madman reputation he wants to be like
Hitler on his heads and he is this
hyperbole didn't go unpunished in
addition to having quals with her work
ethic ba claimed in an interview with GQ
that executive producer Steven Spielberg
demanded her firing ba told the magazine
I wasn't hurt because I know that's just
Megan Megan loves to get a response and
she does it in kind of the wrong way I'm
sorry Megan I'm sorry I made you work 12
hours I'm sorry that I'm making you show
up on time movies are not always warm
and fuzzy